there are renewed concerns that the
trajectory of covid cases in the u.s is
moving in the wrong direction
hospitalization rates are on the
increase as the administration announces
plans to double the number of troops
to bolster the vaccine distribution
effort this
is a record 3.3 million shots were given
on friday pushing the total number of
doses administered
in this country to more than 136 million
all
the number of cases climb in 33 states
michael george is at a mass vaccination
site here in
new york city michael good morning well
jeff
good morning here at the javits center
alone more than a quarter of a million
people have been vaccinated so far
this site is another example of how the
push to vaccinate a nation
is gaining momentum 15 percent of the
country is now
fully vaccinated and among seniors over
65
almost half of them are fully vaccinated
we
have the weapon that wins the war we
have the weapon that kills the enemy
but it has to be here the push for
vaccinations
went into an even higher gear this week
we're opening pop-up centers
everywhere from pop-up centers in new
york
to the salvation army reaching out to
the underserved in los angeles
if you don't have internet access we'll
sign you up on site
the u.s is now one of the top countries
in the world for covid vaccinations
with more to come and 47 states say
anyone 16 or older will be eligible to
get a vaccine by may 1st
new york arkansas and wyoming have yet
to commit
it's clear there is a case for optimism
but there is not a case for relaxation
39 year old alfredo hercules released
from the hospital
shows how serious the pandemic still is
very emotional to see my kids again
because
i haven't seen them in close to three
months amid
spring break celebrating and more states
reopening
boston's mayor had a stern warning this
is not about getting back to normal
normal was hurting too many folks and
still maybe
cases are on the rise in more than half
the states
and many are still dying the seven day
average of deaths
continues to hover at one thousand
deaths per day
i remain deeply concerned about this
trajectory
scientists are still trying to figure
out if vaccinated people can spread the
virus
they're studying 12 000 vaccinated
college students and their contacts
to try and answer that we hope that
within the next
five or so months we'll be able to
answer
the very important question about
whether vaccinated people
get infected asymptomatically and if
they do
do they transmit the infection to others
and u.s vaccine supplies are set to get
a big boost this week
johnson johnson says it's ready to
provide an additional 11 million doses